Now let's take a look at the profile form class in the form package. You
see it finds fields display name, and t-shirt
size. It also defines enum's limit the t-shirt
size, because there is only a certain
range of values for t-shirt size. We're going
to update the safe profile method in conference
API, to restrict the input data to display
name and tee shirt size. it's easy to do
that simply by specifying profile form as the input data
argument. So here I'm looking at the save profile
method in the conference API class, and you'll see I've
passed in profile form as an argument. So, now
that we pass a profile form into the save profile
method, we need to use it. So, I've added the
code to get the display name out of the profile
form, and also to get the t-shirt size out of
the profile form. For the T shirt size, we only
want to set it if the profile form actually sent
it, so we added the conditional check that it's not
now. For the display name, I'm not adding that extra
check because later on, we'll be setting a default display
name based on the user's email, but we don't know
that just yet. Now we can try out our changes.